President Trump will have to decide this
week whether to declassify a democratic
response to a memo alleging FBI
misconduct in the Russia investigation
he Declassified that Republican memo on
Friday well yesterday the president
blasted the lead author of the response
then he used the word treason to
describe the Democrats chilly reaction
to parts of his State of the Union
address he also called them on
american-market Brennan is at the White
House Margaret good morning good morning
well the president was in Cincinnati
yesterday for what was officially billed
as a speech about tax reform but then he
quickly went off script and attacked
Democrats as if it were a campaign rally
it is a sharp departure from the
president's own call for bipartisan
unity made just a week ago in his State
of the Union address they were like
death and an American the president
slammed Democratic lawmakers including
minority leaders Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer for not clapping during his
State of the Union address somebody's a
treasonous I mean yeah I guess why not
can we call that treason why not I mean
they certainly didn't seem to love our
country very much another target of his
ire was congressman Adam Schiff the
president called him little and one of
the biggest liars and leakers in
Washington Schiff believes his
committee's investigation of Trump
campaign ties to Russia and the FBI
probe led by Special Counsel Robert
Muller are closing in on the president
there is a rising sense of panic clearly
within the White House and as well on
the hill
the House Intelligence Committee voted
Monday to release a ten page memo from
Democrats meant to rebut Republican
accusations of political bias at the FBI
when it requested warrants to spy on
former Trump campaign aide Carter page
its release depends on whether President
Trump D classifies it in Cincinnati the
president seemed to celebrate the
release of the Republican memo oh but
did we catch them in the act or what you
know what I'm done oh did we catch them
in the act
they are very embarrassed they never
thought they were to get caught we
caught them
hey we caught a lot so much fun we're
like the great sleuth now Carter Paige
who had been on the FBI's radar since
back in 2013 for past contact with
Russian operatives said last night that
in his view anyone on the Trump campaign
with any kind of positive or negative
connection to Russia has automatically
become a target for suspicion and Nora
he said all of it is simply a witch-hunt
Margit let me ask you about what the New
York Times is reporting this morning
that the president's lawyers are
advising him against sitting down for a
wide-ranging interview a special
counselor counseled Muller what do you
know about that well Nora the president
has said that he would be willing to
speak with the special counsel but only
if his lawyers allow it and from what we
understand his lawyers are still
discussing this and trying to narrow the
scope of questioning to try to avoid any
kind of legal traps and here's what we
understand they're sort of ground rules
are from making this decision one is the
accusation truly a serious crime - is
there proof that there's simply no other
way to find the answers to these
questions and three they don't want any
kind of fishing expedition so yesterday
one of president Trump's lawyers John
Dowd told CBS News that discussions are
still underway for a possible interview
Mary Margaret